- [Instructor] In this
video we're going to talk
about what is one of the darkest chapters
in human history, the Holocaust,
which involved the massacre
of roughly 6 million Jews
and as many as 11 million
civilians in total.
In order to understand the Holocaust,
we're going to start at World War I.
Even prior to World War
I, there were massacres,
especially of Jews, in places
like the Russian empire.
The term pogrom is a Russian word
meaning these violent riots or attacks
on people for their ethnicity.
There were several
through the 19th century.
But they go back even
before that word was coined
as early as the first crusades.
Famously in the Rhineland,
many of the Jewish people
were killed and attacked.
You had a solid thread of antisemitism
throughout much of Europe,
including Germany and Eastern Europe
as we get up to and through World War I.
As we've talked about in other videos,
the central powers lose World War I
and the Treaty of Versailles places a lot
of the blame on Germany.
The national pride of
Germany has been shattered.
They have lost this war.
They have lost territory.
Their economy is in shambles.
They're paying reparations.
It is in that context
that the National Socialist Party forms
officially in 1920, coming out
of the German Workers Party.
They focused on ideas of national identity
and from the start were
against ethnic groups,
blaming their problems,
including the loss of World War I
often on these ethnic groups.
In 1921, Hitler, who had
fought during World War I
and based on some of his writings
seemed to have found a lot
of meaning during the war,
he becomes the National
Socialist Party leader.
National Socialist, it gets abbreviated
as Nazi, National Socialist
Party, Nazi Party.
In 1923, Hitler tries
to begin an overthrow
of the government.
But his putsch, his coup, is unsuccessful
and he is imprisoned.
It is while in prison that he writes
down his belief system that
eventually gets published
upon his release in 1925
under the title Mein Kampf,
which can be translated as
my struggle or my battle.
This is just an excerpt from Mein Kampf.
"If we pass all the causes of
the German collapse in review,
"the ultimate and most
decisive remains the failure
"to recognize the racial problem
"and especially the Jewish menace.
"The defeats on the
battlefield in August, 1918,"
so he's referring the end of World War I,
"Would have been child's play to bear.
"They stood in no
proportion to the victories
"of our people.
"It was not they that
caused our downfall, no.
"It was brought about by
that power which prepared
"these defeats by systematically,
over many decades,
"robbing our people of the
political and moral instincts
"and forces which alone
make nations capable
"and hence worthy of existence."
He's blaming Germany's
defeat in World War I
on a relatively small ethnic group.
So, as you can see, a very twisted mind,
very twisted thinking.
"The lost purity of the blood alone
"destroys inner happiness forever,"
so he's very caught up
with these ideas of purity,
"Plunges man into the abyss for all time,
"and the consequences can
never more be eliminated
"from body and spirit."
Over time, what starts
off as this fringe leader
of a fringe party, as we go into the 20s
and as the German economy gets even worse
and there's hyperinflation,
more and more people start
to throw their support
behind these extremists.
And as we go into the 30s,
the National Socialist Party
is actually able to get
reasonable representation
in the German parliament.
In 1933, the president of Germany
appoints Hitler to be chancellor,
which is the equivalent
of being prime minister
despite the Nazis not having
a majority in parliament.
This is the official
beginning of what the Nazis
will call the Third Reich.
Reich translates as realm.
They considered the First Reich
to be the holy Roman Empire.
They refer to the Second
Reich as the German Empire
after the holy Roman Empire up
and through World War I.
They don't consider the Weimar Republic,
which they hate, the Third Reich.
They consider that the interim Reich.
And they consider
themselves the Third Reich,
the heir to the German Empire
and the holy Roman Empire.
Once Hitler and the Nazis get power,
they really get a strangle hold on it.
They start persecuting
their political opponents
both, outside the party,
and inside the party.
They also start to take
action on these twisted ideas
Hitler expressed in Mein Kampf.
In 1935, they're able to
pass the Nuremberg Laws,
which strips German Jews
of their citizenship.
It forbids intermarrying
between non-Jewish Germans
and Jews.
This is only one of many
steps that will continue
to demean the rights of
Jews inside of Germany.
In 1938, you have what is
known as Kristallnacht,
or the night of broken glass.
Hundred of synagogues are burned.
Thousands of Jewish
businesses are destroyed
and many Jews are killed in that night.
Then as we get into 1939,
Hitlers' armies famously invade Poland
beginning what many historians consider
to be the start of World War II.
What would eventually be
known as the Holocaust
goes into full effect in 1941.
Jews are sometimes
executed in the streets,
in their homes, many of them are captured
and sent to concentration camps.
To get a sense of the
scale of this operation,
we have this excerpt from
Michael Berenbaum's book,
The World Must Know.
"The policy of extermination
involved every level
"of German society and
marshaled the entire apparatus
"of the German bureaucracy.
"Parish churches and the
Interior Ministry supplied
"the birth records that
defined and isolated Jews.
"The post office delivered
the notifications
"of definition, expropriation,
denaturalization,
"and deportation.
"The Finance Ministry
confiscated Jewish wealth
"and property.
"German industrial and commercial firms
"fired Jewish workers,
officers, and board members,
"even disenfranchising
Jewish stockholders.
"The universities refused
to admit Jewish students,
"denied degrees to those already enrolled,
"and dismissed Jewish faculty.
"government transportation bureaus handled
"the billing arrangements
with the railroads
"for the trains that carried
Jews to their death."
The point that's being
made here is this could not
be done just with Hitler and
some of his close associates.
To kill millions of people on this scale,
you needed and entire apparatus.
And hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of people
were involved in some way.
At least several hundreds
of thousands of people
within Germany must have been
aware of what was happening.
Needless to say, the death
toll was considerable.
This here is a visual depiction
of the percentage of the Jewish population
that was killed in various regions.
As you can see, 80 to 90
percent of the Jewish population
in Germany, Czechoslovakia, Poland,
was killed during the Holocaust.
In the territories occupied
by Germany in Russia
during World War II, almost
as many had been killed.
In France, Italy, 1/5 to 1/4
of the population was killed.
To put things more in human terms,
this is a picture of children
who were in Auschwitz,
one of the most infamous
concentration camps.
You can see their names, their ages,
and then when they were killed.
Historians believe five
to six million Jews
were killed during the Holocaust
including a million and a half children.
This was 2/3 of the Jewish
population of Europe.
But the Holocaust went further.
It's believed that over
10 million civilians
were killed during the Holocaust.
Over three million prisoners
of war were killed.
And other people including
several hundred thousand Romani,
often referred to as Gypsies.
Several hundred thousand
people with disabilities,
many thousands of homosexuals
were all put to death
during the Holocaust.
We've covered a lot of world history.
A lot of it, unfortunately,
has a lot of death,
a lot of destruction and
sometimes targeting people
for their ethnicity.
But never, in world history,
have we seen something
at this scale.
Because it seemed to be
a relatively new concept,
a term was coined, genocide.
It was coined by Raphael Lemkin who,
as a Holocaust survivor, had
49 members of his family killed
during the Holocaust.
It means killing of a people.
Geno, coming from a people or a family,
and cide, killing.
But maybe even more interesting
than the word definition itself,
is thinking about why
this actually happened.
Maybe even more importantly,
how society can avoid it.
I'll leave you with that question.
What do you think was the
reason why this happened?
And do you think we have a risk
of that happening in the future?
And how can we prevent it?